By the time "Innuendo" was released in 1991,...
...it was impossible to disguise that Freddie was seriously ill.
Despite his frail appearance, the band continued to make videos in support of the album.
We made a whole album, "Innuendo", knowing that this was happening.
If you listen to it now, it's made with the knowledge that we don't have much longer.
And Freddie doesn't have much longer on the planet.
Freddie retired to the privacy of his Kensington Estate.
Britain's tabloid press stalked him night and day,...
...turning him into a prisoner in his own home.
His friends insisted that nothing was wrong.
But finally, Freddie could no longer hide his secret.
On Saturday, November 23, 1991,...
...he released a statement to the press acknowledging that he had AIDS.
A little over 24 hours after issuing the statement, Freddie Mercury died.
He was 46 years old.
Freddie left a bulk of his estate to his soul mate Mary Austin.
Fans from all over the world sent cards and flowers.
A small cremation service was held three days after his death,..
...conducted in the ancient Zoroastrian faith of Freddie's parents.
Farrokh Bulsara had finally come home.